[Musique]
des citoyens en colère après le drame
ont pris d'assaut les rues du 10e
arrondissement
gaz lacrymogène a été tiré par les
policiers les manifestants ont répliqué
avec des projectiles
plutôt un homme de 69 ans d'un
nationalité française aurait fait feu à
trois endroits dans un centre
communautaire Kurdes un restaurant et un
salon de coiffure on connaît déjà qui
travaillent à la salon de coiffure on
est rentré dans le salon de coiffure on
a vu qu'on a les gens ils l'ont
interpellé un mec un monsieur assez âgé
un peu âgé grand tout et il y a trois
blessés dans le salon des éléments
préliminaires laissent croire que la
communauté kurde pourrait avoir été la
cible l'an dernier l'homme avait été
arrêté pour tentative d'homicide après
avoir attaqué un camp de migrants avec
un sabre il venait d'être libéré dans un
gazouillis le président de la République
française déclare que les Kurdes de
France ont été la cible d'une odieuse
attaque au cœur de Paris la procureur
rappelle que l'enquête ne fait que
commencer dans tout motif raciste des
faits et bien ces motifs vont évidemment
faire partie des investigations qui
viennent de débuter encore une fois avec
un très grand déploiement d'effectif le
ministre de l'Intérieur annonce une
présence policière accrue j'ai demandé à
tous les services de police et de
gendarmerie à Paris bien sûr et ailleurs
sur le territoire national de protéger
particulièrement avec des gardes
statiques 24 heures sur 24 des policiers
des gendarmes les lieux où se réunissent
la communauté kurde
les violences surviennent dans un
contexte de tension pour la communauté
kurde il y a 10 ans 3 militantes ont été
tués dans le même quartier en tram de
fond il y a également le conflit kurde
qui perdure en Turquie
Montréal